o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já mais um vídeo
e ou estragos equipe nos crise isto mas
fazer um vídeo turístico no chile méxico
crise comentou controlar eu comprei o
wifi e 3g s bulls não duas não é o blush
é caro pra [ __ ] eo compromisso social
espanhol para gravar jogos de iphone e
hell's kitchen pessoal ultimamente o
tornado viciado pra [ __ ] vicia muito
num jogo que eu dar sinais
vocês pensaram em 69 o ato sexual em que
a mulher está por cima do opera em que o
homem está caralhão sei como é que fica
próxima de janeiro um sonho nunca fiz
gelo
eu fiz a pergunta ou seja o que eu dar
sinais ainda que o que é isso
basicamente um jogo de tarde estar do
estado isso jogo mas para o iphone
iphone android tem por tudo é extinguir
tudo até na por micro ondas lá por favor
não dá pra cada nível do estilo geek
falou um dia do começo eu já tô sofrendo
portanto já passei por janeiro março e
abril não [ __ ] não pega janeiro pelas
obras de janeiro botafogo e eu pensava
que me passado mas não vamos achar um
furo voltar aqui traz para explicar como
é que funciona né mas não só eu mostrar
que eu me pergunto pra vocês verem a
data 11 de janeiro conjugar todos em
qualquer lugar na tela por atirar dardos
muito sim é um jogador que mais cresce
consegue chegar a estréia é muito
simples basicamente vou ter cinco tardes
parece estar na minha como é que se
chama eu não sei eu tenho uma tábua de
madeira com jato viciado e este tipo tem
14 pra mim é muito fácil é muito simples
o op muitos inclusive conseguiu isso o
nível é muito fácil agora vamos para o
nível 2 e que detém este jogo é
eficiente para caraças quando você pega
unificar como assim quando você está em
um nicho que não conseguem largar meu
que está a passar com o meu dinheiro
bebido eu não teve foi assim dentro do
ataque agora vai agora vai o álbum já
estavam já tá bom o segundo é que ao bem
na ponta bem da polícia não fale isso
aqui é e
entre espaciais o forró é muito difícil
o nome da gripe o luca pergunto desiro
falta um batom e vai encaixar num e-mail
e o último vai subir com um chute fácil
muito simples muito divertido e eu vou
passar o nível 3 só pra vocês já se
ambientarem só vou usar sim cuidar dos
itens que você tá aqui é que basta
vencer com apenas em maio já primeiro
lugar é que isto pode parecer fácil mas
é difícil nos vencer mas em outro
veículo difícil quando lutava muito jogo
está a ganhar tanto é mais fácil pegar
por conceito mais concentrados
eu sou eu na frente o ovo conseguir é
que está a mais no nível passado o
palmas pra mim sou button button mas de
lá para cá e vamos começar agora a
história porque mudam funk é um nível
onde isto mas calma a tensão tem um
surfe o cno maio um dos desafio vamos
experimentar aqui um pouco o jogo
alimentar não desculpe a não descuidar
porque porque eu tenho um foco em
escorpião não é isso como podem ver eu
tenho aqui uma moeda como escorpião lá
dentro é assim que matou escorpiões com
a moeda bem duro aqui dentro é um
escorpião real mesmo e isso não é
brincadeira é real e um outro ícone
laranja ora aí está aqui bem gostosa pra
cá aqui discutir ingredientes são os
corpos depois não me digas a sério essa
série que tem escorpião o céu eo resto é
a moeda 9960 moeda eu não sei quem é que
sabe e nunca experimentei e o desafio
vai ser o seguinte cada vez que eu não
passar o nível eu vou ter que encarar um
pouco deste chupa-chupa nesta moeda rija
que não sei que tirar mas sánchez sabem
se estivesse no morro eo arriscar a
minha vida por vocês portanto sua ao
apoio instruírem o que cada vez que eu
não passar o nível que eu vou dar uma
trinca nesta coisa nessa mulher ministro
escorpião olha no que deu como escorpião
vamos lá voltamos na praia as garotas
maravilha e o contrato lembo em que eu
comprei aqui tipo raio laser que pra
acertar mais fácil os tetras vejam só
como está difícil está o x tudo já se
tem uma duas vai 35
como é que eu vou encaixar aqui mais
incertas num barranco se não viu
e com assim está colado dentro vai dar
que o dark dos frangos vai ter calma
lu continuar assim nunca mais acaba
sempre estava em risco agora que vou
conseguir mas agora só faltam duas só
faltam duas
eu consigo última pessoal é o último de
cacharel nenê por cento fifa laser custa
99 cêntimos puxa comprar não voltar a
comprar joventino sempre está aqui em
picos corinthians a sair
a canalhice miro lei burrito escorpião
[ __ ] muita calma nessa hora
o rei do das 69 está aqui presente não
faço aqui um desafio pessoal se vocês
conseguirem chegar até esse nível 24 de
fevereiro eo tipo tipo siga nos no
twitter é pois tem para criar uma imagem
dizer que vocês passaram estímulo vai
faltar 16 foco em certas não sai andré
meninos entre escorpião salvou que fazer
um big box estudar 69 olha só eu tô aqui
vamos tentar outra vez agora nos beats
que o cachorro pokémon go eo pikachu era
chá nêto não é um chinês do oeste com 11
eo eu tenho um pikachu shine tudo ao
sair mary
agora estou confiante não senti isto
sentir o poder da vitória
tiro o air homem por uma certa do dardo
69 e escorando com cinto vôo hotel como
assim eu não toquei vocês viram está
errado
já vou ficar em itajá publicar edital
tem passagens ainda muito rápido muito
rápido ou muito muito rápido não dá no
bairro agora escorpião o photo uma falta
como é que eu vou encaixar essa uma
contém um disco assim eu vou tentar
enfiar lá até agora [ __ ] poder de
iluminação e ai ai ai que pena que o
fogo tenha citado equaciona um símbolo
do nosso escorpião
estou super curioso perceber a que sabe
não escorpião por isso vamos tentar
abril porque eu tenho preguiça de
landeira isto tudo é isto não há de ser
pior do que a larva na hora você vinha
muito mal mesmo mas vamos comer o nosso
amigo escorpião as idéias é e vamos
partir do escorpião e agora tá na hora
na hora do show [ __ ] elson
só que você já consegue ver um escorpião
avaí e goiás está dormindo banho
olha aí o pico de um tratado for aí
canalha ou muito venenoso isso porque é
muito porosa
agora vou porque o lixão
meu deus eu fui campeão partiu da vivo
meu deus não não isso é muito nojento
por aí que um próximo eu falei [ __ ]
isso é muito nojento eu não vou comer
isso que esta parte do corpo do
escorpião eu vou agora comer e ver se é
bom assegurou cipullo não consegui
encontrar mais parte porque está tudo
parte né mas vamos lutar esta corja não
criou olha no que deu
não sei se vocês conseguem ver mas tem
aqui uma parte do e viscosa o é o
[ __ ] 321 pai
ó mãe é a lei e não o horário é isso seu
olho é perceber qualquer coisa estranha
que pediram ainda sistemas há mais
qualquer coisa pois já expliquei nem eu
nem sei como está que qualquer corpo
docente mas já sabem sou baixinho jogo
mas não conseguem chegar até o nivel 24
fred se vocês conseguirem o segundo ao
twitter
inclusive o andré também está a fazer
isto porque eu também está viciado pra
[ __ ] também passará pelo canal também
porque eu também vai fazer vídeo e só
quando thomas aiken favorito fimma e da
próxima semana
nunca mais